[Musica]
lo spazio va vissuto
non va riempito
soprattutto se vogliamo accorciare le
distanze
questo minuto che ho voluto fare io
introduttivo era è una ho cercato almeno
di provare a farvi percepire che cosa
voleva dire un momento di pausa un
momento di silenzio perché si pensa
allora che il silenzio che è una pausa
che i vuoti siano vuoti che non
contengano qualcosa in realtà non è vero
che non c'era niente perché c'era
curiosità da parte vostra da parte mia
anche la curiosità di guardare con calma
bene questo teatro invece di iniziare
subito a parlare c'era emozione c'è la
vibrazione c'è vibrazione perché tutto
vibra i colori i suoni soprattutto la
materia il nostro battito cardiaco il
respiro
Allora perché si tende a pensare sempre
che i vuoti e gli spazi debbano essere
riempiti
i silenzi gli spazi i vuoti le pause
viverli significa ascoltarli
e rispettarli in modo che loro possano
nutrirsi
e proteggerci sono fondamentalmente
portatori di opportunità di guarigione e
di felicità Se voi ci pensate
nell'universo non c'è tutto a
cartocciato no Se guardiamo le stelle
hanno un loro spazio vitale
i boschi le piante i fili d'erba se ci
avviciniamo a noi i nostri organi
interni le note musicali su uno spartito
su un rigo Provate a immaginarvi se
fossero tutti accartocciati
perché viviamo Allora una società dove
ci viene costantemente detto e ricordato
h24 che dobbiamo fare dobbiamo correre
dobbiamo riempire sembra che avere uno
spazio avrà un momento di défaillance
avere fra l'altro ci fate caso non ci si
incanta più Io mi ricordo quando ero
piccola che ogni tanto rimanevo così
Oh Rosita mia madre no questo gesto non
lo vedo più non esiste più
E questo porta a una serie di
conseguenze il fatto di non dedicare uno
spazio al nostro interno al nostro
interiore alla nostra mente come i
nostri sentimenti no tutto ciò che
accade di negativo è sbagliato gode
della nostra complicità quotidiana
perché noi siamo sempre sempre di più
Pensiamo che tutto quello che accade di
grande intorno a noi come soprattutto in
questi ultimi periodi diventa sempre più
evidente la crisi climatica le malattie
le guerre
l'ambiente siamo tutti responsabili di
questo siamo tutti responsabili perché
noi compiamo un'azione politica ogni
giorno e diverse volte al giorno e
quindi non possiamo ogni volta delegare
e dare la responsabilità di tutto quello
che succede sia lontano di noi o nella
comunità o vicino a noi sempre agli
altri ecco perché siamo complici perché
ogni volta che noi per esempio andiamo a
comperare qualcosa finanziamo Qualcosa E
se non abbiamo spazio nella mente per
iniziare di nuovo a domandarci
che cosa sto finanziando con questa
azione dietro questo indumento che
compro il cibo che compro cosa c'è
dietro il lavoro di chi lo sfruttamento
di chi il dolore di quale animale
e quindi bisogna ricominciare a decidere
se vogliamo continuare a stare dalla
parte del problema e ce ne sono tanti
oggi o iniziare a stare dalla parte
della soluzione perché c'è una soluzione
per tutto c'è assolutamente una
soluzione per tutto Non lo dico Non lo
dico io che non sono non sono nessuno
Non sono uno scienziato non sono un
filosofo non sono un insegnante però
leggo tanto Sono molto curiosa
e se voglio cambiare il mondo devo
cominciare a cambiare me stessa quindi
smetterla di dare la responsabilità di
tutto quello che mi capita qualcun altro
eh Sono triste sono depresso per colpa
di mio marito di mia moglie sono
incazzato per colpa della politica per
colpa del lavoro per colpa
dell'imprenditore No è tutto è tutto
parte da noi
parte solo ed esclusivamente tutto
quanto da noi
quindi
Dobbiamo iniziare a prenderci degli
spazi Vitali fondamentali
dobbiamo soffermarci No io ho fatto
questo minuto all'inizio ma
viviamo una vita tutta di corsa che poi
se uno ci pensa bene dove si va poi
andiamo correndo verso che cosa
adesso ci sono un sacco di frasi che
sono diventate da parte dei delle grosse
menti pubblicitarie no come degli
Imprenditori come dei media hanno capito
che funzionano tipo il qui e ora la
consapevolezza la meditazione però cosa
c'è dietro tutte queste cose qua Per
esempio imparare a vivere il qui E ora
basta guardare una pianta o basta basta
guardare un animale gli animali vivono
solamente il presente non sono
proiettati in un futuro che non c'è Se
tu non vivi il presente in un passato
che è già andato
e viviamo in queste società
che continuano con questa televisione
che funziona questi media che funzionano
24 ore su 24 che continuano a dirci che
dobbiamo riempire riempire comprare
comprare
mangiare ingozzarci produrre produrre
produrre cose inutili che durano poche
poi si buttano che vengono costruite
apposta perché in un determinato momento
si rompano e non esistono più i pezzi di
ricambio questa vita usa e getta non è
solamente con gli oggetti e anche dentro
di noi Ci sono relazioni oramai usa e
getta tanto che se ne frega si dice no
Morto un Papa se ne fa un altro mi Mollo
con un fidanzato con un marito con una
moglie Ne troverà un altro e nel
frattempo dentro di noi
perdiamo quella felicità che ci dicono
che di cui dobbiamo accontentarci
solamente a sprazzi ma che in realtà non
è vero perché noi possiamo essere felici
24 ore su 24 ma è qualcosa che dobbiamo
assimilare interiormente non si può
spiegare
e quindi mentre noi finanziamo che i
nostri soldi
l'industria della moda l'industria
alimentare che sono le due Industrie
soprattutto responsabili di tutto quello
che sta succedendo di carenza d'acqua di
povertà del mondo di disboscamenti
chi se ne fregano tanto noi non vediamo
noi viviamo nei paesi industrializzati
noi vediamo delle cose diverse quindi
chi se ne frega se nel Ghana tutti i
nostri vestiti finiscono lì dove ci sono
bambini che giocano in mezzo alla
tossicità di e qui vedete poco perché
una montagna di roba e ci sono mucche
che mangiano cercano da mangiare
magrissime lì a me che mi importa Sì lo
so che c'è il terzo mondo c'è gente che
lavora e viene sfruttato perché io possa
avere un vestito carino e griffato
faccio finta di niente Chi se ne frega
no se devono scuoiare vivo un
coccodrillo per avere una borsetta
griffata oppure spennare viva un'oca per
avere il piumino d'oca che peraltro
tiene anche meno caldo di quelli
ecologici fra parentesi
chi se ne frega del cibo Io vado al
supermercato c'ho tutto quello che
voglio senza seguire nemmeno più le
stagioni adesso no vado lì compro e non
me ne frega niente di vedere se c'è un
Patch un Packaging di plastica e siamo
sommersi nella plastica fino qua perché
non sappiamo più cosa farci E dove
metterla imparare a finanziare questa
roba qui e a decidere di comprare per
esempio qualcosa che non è avvolto nella
plastica la stessa cosa che peraltro
sarà pure più sana
e senza parlare degli allevamenti
intensivi
si parla tanto di fare attenzione
all'acqua no ci viene detto Mi
raccomando c'è fra un po' la anzi già
adesso L'acqua è poca e che anche per La
siccità chiudiamo il rubinetto mentre ci
laviamo i denti Peccato che non vi
dicono che per fare una bistecca un
chilo di carne servono
14.000 litri di acqua potabile
Senza contare la sofferenza che viene
inflitta a tutti questi animali che
provano esattamente le stesse nostre
emozioni quindi paura dolore sgomento
stress gioia e felicità se glielo
concediamo E allora se guardiamo bene
noi e loro Io ultimamente non noto tanta
differenza forse lì i polli ci hanno un
attimo le sbarre Ma le sbarre nostre
sono sbarre mentali Se continuiamo a
riempire il nostro spazio mentale Se
continuiamo a non darci il tempo di
fermarci e anche annoiarci un po' nel
senso nobile della parola noia e la
creatività dei grandi artisti se ci
pensate nasce proprio da dallo spazio
vuoto
Michelangelo pistoletto dice che Come
eredità lui lascerà uno spazio vuoto la
creatività nasce da lì le idee vengono
da lì
siamo l'ultima catena secondo me noi
umani di una sperimentazione globale
molto più grande di noi che è iniziata
tanti anni fa e non è recente solamente
perché gli ultimi tre anni ci hanno
messo alle corde
però questo è quello che penso e quindi
oggi sono venuta qui volentieri perché
volevo condividere con voi i miei
pensieri quello che ho vissuto su di me
Sono fermamente convinta che l'unica
soluzione sia riappropriarsi in maniera
Laica o religiosa ma autonoma del
proprio spazio individuale bisogna
ricominciare ad avere una coscienza
etica non possiamo più fregarcene non
possiamo più non c'è più tempo
ed è una trappola culturale credere che
lo spazio sia vuoto il vuoto in sé non
esiste È solo una proiezione delle
nostre paure il vuoto Non esiste il
silenzio non esiste anche se ci sembra
di non percepirlo c'è già qualcosa in
questo vuoto bisogna farlo nostro
vivere la vita invece di pensarla
liberare lo spazio mentale lasciarlo
agire È così che il mio Spazio Interiore
svuotandosi ed emozioni disturbanti si
riempiva di spazi Vitali Questo è quello
che io ho fatto nel periodo più
difficile della mia vita io ho 58 anni
suonati e tre anni fa durante la
pandemia mi sono trovata come tutti noi
in tutto il mondo in una condizione
è terrificante ho avuto la fortuna di
capire in fretta che dovevo spegnere la
televisione e non farmi massacrare
psicologicamente e fisicamente dal
terrorismo mediatico che mi stava
condizionando sono andata di nascosto
una volta in piazza del Duomo e nel
silenzio e nel profumo di una città che
sa solo di tubo di scappamento come
Milano di botto profumava di aria vedere
quest'opera fatta da uomini illuminati
pensata da uomini illuminati mi sono
commosso ho iniziato a ringraziare
Bisogna tornare ad essere grati anche di
quel poco che si ha bisogna tornare ad
avere dignità
una volta l'insegnamento venivano dai
genitori o dai Come si dice le prime
figure erano i genitori e i maestri Ma
se oggi la mentalità è scelgo il male
minore e badate bene il male minore
quindi già si sa che si sta scegliendo
qualcosa di male non posso so che è
sbagliato ma non posso rinunciare perché
non posso perdere il lavoro se si
continua ad avere paura i figli avranno
un esempio davanti a noi di
padri che si chinano di fronte a un
ricatto
invece di avere un padre con la spina
dorsale di un padre una madre un
insegnante con la spina dorsale dritta
che ti fa vedere con dignità che si può
essere un pochino più poveri ma
dignitosi
se vuoi conoscere davvero la vita devi
lasciare andare tutto quello che pensi
di sapere è a quel punto conoscerai
tutto quello che c'è da conoscere
i vuoti sono pesanti Sono fermi
sono faticosi sono legati a delle
aspettative che verranno sempre tradite
invece
cioè scusate i piedi sono pesanti non i
vuoti il vuoto invece è leggero è
dinamico e libertà è pronto aperto alla
curiosità e non ha confini
bisogna indagare l'essenza della realtà
attraverso
indagare l'essenza della realtà
attraverso un dito su uno schermo non è
come vivere attraverso tutti i cinque
sensi un'emozione bella o brutta che sia
vi voglio lasciare con questo oggi si
dice che si accorciano le distanze
perché attraverso un tablet un computer
riusciamo a parlare con qualcuno lontano
No dalla parte opposta del mondo è vero
Lì per lì la accorciamo un pochino la
distanza ma in realtà non è vero perché
non ci sarà computer intelligenza
come dice telematica non ci sarà Siri
non ci sarà metaverso adesso ci sarà
questo metaverso questa
voglio dire tutti questi computer e
questi robot che fanno le cose per noi
si rispegni la luce Siri Alzami la
musica Noi rimaniamo fermi su un divano
seduti su una macchina seduti in una
scrivania il nostro corpo è fatto per
essere per stare in movimento è solo
così non ci ammaliamo non solo
fisicamente ma anche mentalmente
nonostante l'intelligenza artificiale
più grande del mondo e per quanto
possono essere imbattibili per certi
versi le macchine non sapranno mai mai
fare una cosa non riusciranno mai ad
avere l'empatia l'empatia vuol dire
sentire l'altro ma sentire col cuore
sentire la tua felicità il tuo dolore la
tua preoccupazione
e sarà l'empatia che salverà l'umanità
perché il mondo senza di noi va avanti
lo stesso è forse anche meglio
e quindi se c'è un augurio che vi voglio
fare è provate d'ora in poi a
soffermarvi a ringraziare di essere in
quel momento dire grazie che ci sono e
che mi sto rendendo conto che ci sono
Grazie che sbaglio
Grazie che sto ancora
come dice che sto ancora che parlo che
vedo non dare più scontato niente che
abbiamo due gamberi c'è gente meno
fortunata di noi e che Ringrazia più di
noi che abbiamo abbastanza volte anche
troppo
dobbiamo togliere invece che mettere
e non c'è niente come vedere lo sguardo
di persone di un'altra persona avere una
carezza un abbraccio
e sentire il respiro il cuore di un
altro che possa veramente aiutarci a
essere felici perché si può essere
felici 24 ore su 24 invece di
accontentarci di picchi di felicità
una volta che sei felice non si smette
di soffrire ma Si vivrà il dolore la
sofferenza le preoccupazioni in un altro
modo
quindi gratitudine
felicità
dignità ed empatia Questo è per me sono
le quattro parole che possono veramente
renderci persone migliori Grazie